this video is brought to you by nebula
watch our bonus videos with F-16 test
pilot David Kar by signing up to nebula
for only 250 a
month a fully loaded F-16 is a force to
be reckoned with an air superiority
machine that countries the world over
use to patrol their Skies a lowcost
lightweight single engine fighter
specifically designed to outmaneuver its
opponents while carrying state-of-the
missiles that would hopefully mean it
would never have to the F-16 was born
out of the Vietnam War large heavy
complex us Fighters like the F4 Phantom
were the norm but the F4 found itself in
Peril frequently at a significant
disadvantage when taking on the smaller
maneuverable soviet-made migs of the
Vietnamese Air Force like the
mig21 the mig21 was a small single-
engined lightweight aircraft with thin
Delta Wings the F4 was fast flying up to
to mock 2.2 traveled further and carried
more missiles with a powerful radar but
its lack of maneuverability at low speed
poor pilot visibility and easy
identification due to jet engines that
billowed black smoke Trails made it
vulnerable to snake attacks from the
Soviet Interceptor Mig 21s frequently
flew close to the ground under radar and
ambushed incoming f4s making a single
attacking run with their ATL infrared
guided missiles and then using their
lows speed maneuverability to outturn
and escape from August 1967 to February
1968 us losses in Vietnam were
staggering losing 18 aircraft while
Downing just five for a nation
accustomed to Absolute Air superiority
something was off the Mig 21's
introduction in 1966 forced the US to
adapt its large heavy fighter bombers
while useful were at a disadvantage
against these smaller cheaper planes and
something needed to be done the Red
Baron study commissioned by the US
military began to identify and address
the Tactical and technical issues
causing the heavy losses that both the
US Navy and Air Force were experiencing
in the Vietnam War and their findings
led to the development of one of the
world's most ubiquitous fighter planes a
plane designed with a new physics-based
doctrine at its core entering service in
1978 and standing the test of time it is
now confirmed that the aircraft will be
entering the battle for Ukraine's
Freedom taking on the modern-day
counterparts of the Mig this is the
insane engineering of the
F-16 the F-16 was built from the ground
up with this classified 1966 paper as
its Guiding Light a paper full of
mathematical models graphs and equations
designed to answer one question how to
win a Close Quarters dog fight create
created with the help of military
supercomputers it defined A New Concept
energy maneuverability created by
Colonel John Boy an Air Force veteran of
the Vietnam War and one of the members
of the so-called fighter Mafia with the
help of a civilian mathematician Thomas
Christie these graphs were the basis for
defining a plane's maneuverability
through its full range of speeds mock
number on the x-axis turn rate on the y
a theory underlined by the management of
both kinetic and and potential energy
speed and altitude in order to change
direction a fighter aircraft must trade
energy from these reservoirs and doing
it as efficiently as possible is the key
to outmaneuvering an enemy this is the
energy maneuverability diagram for the
F-16 it's a complicated graph to read
without some basic understanding this
line is defined by the maximum lift of
the aircraft this is important because
it determines the maximum turn rate at a
particular speed in this region we need
lift to turn to begin a turn an aircraft
will roll in the direction of the turn
this splits the lift the plane is
generating into two components a
horizontal component that causes the
plane to turn and a vertical component
that keeps the plane in the sky a
steeper Bank angle will increase the
horizontal component and increase our
turn rate while stealing lift from the
vertical component this vertical
component needs to equal the weight of
the aircraft or the plane will lose
altitude to compensate for that the
pilot will need to increase lift by
increasing the angle of attack this is
where the maximum lift issue arises more
lift means more available Force to turn
to determine the max turn rate for an
F-16 at4 Mach we simply draw a line
straight up and across to our turn rate
13° per second now this is where things
get interesting this is the graph for an
f4e at the same speed speed the F4 can
make a maximum turn of just 5° per
second to determine a sustained turn we
look to this line labeled with a zero
meaning no loss of altitude is required
to make the turn we can see the f-16's
best sustained turn is 14.2 de per
second at 0.85 Mach at 7g the f4s best
sustained turn is 10° per second at 0.85
Mach at 5G this is what that looks like
in practice it takes the F16 25 seconds
to complete a full 360° turn while it
takes the F4 36 seconds 11 seconds in
the
difference the F-16 was a radical new
way of thinking about fighter aircraft
and that design philosophy can be seen
with how the engine Inlet has been
designed to deal with supersonic flow to
learn more about the F-16 we spoke with
an F-16 test pilot so the the F-16 Inlet
is one one of those things that tells
you about the design philosophy of the
aircraft because up until that point the
thought process was we wanted to go
faster we wanted to go higher and nobody
stopped to ask why because it turns out
that not a lot of fights not a lot of
Air Combat was happening in that Mach 2
plus range in fact very little of it was
happening and it didn't have a huge
amount of
tactical application and so as
John Boyd and the rest of the team was
looking at this lightweight fighter
design which became the F-16 they said
well where where do we think that the
dog fights of the future are really
going to happen and they said well it's
probably going to be somewhere in that
point8 mock to 1.2 mock regime that's
really where we need to be in terms of
optimizing the performance of the the
Jet and we see that here in terms of the
specific accs power chart where it's got
this this Advantage right here in that
range of8 Mach to 1.2 Mach that's where
the fat part of the chart sits that's
where you're fat on energy that's where
you have that advantage and so the
F-16 propulsion system is not optimized
to go over Mach 2 although it can and
I've flown the F-16 at Mach 2 you run
out of gas pretty quick but you can go
that fast but in that what we call
transonic regime of point to 1.2 Mach
you've got a different design problem
than some of the previous Jets and you
can see that in terms of the inlets the
inlets on the
F4 have this extension that goes sort of
along the cheeks of the aircraft forward
and then the actual Inlet is inlets are
set back and what that's designed to do
is attach a shock wave to the front of
that Inlet lip and then it goes
backwards and expands along the the body
and that shock wave is basically going
to cover up the
inlet that has some thermodynamic
effects in terms of pressure recovery
for the fan face because you don't want
supersonic air getting all the way in to
your turbine if you have suponic air
flow hitting the front face of that jet
engine the jet engine is going to
disintegrate it's designed to ingest
subsonic air flow and so you have to
attach that shock wave at the front of
the
inlet that's part of what slows down the
air flow to eventually a normal shock
inside the inlet it expands a little bit
and then it gets to the the front face
of the compressor the fan face of the
compressor well the F-16 and you can see
it right here has what we call a pedo
Inlet it's basically a flat face air
scoop it is not that sort of uh overhang
with a a lip and then an inlet that's
further back like you see on the F4 or
the F-15 or the
F14 the MiG 29 the su27 all of those
have more of that that Inlet that's set
up to put an oblique shock wave across
the front of the inlet those are
designed to go faster the F-16 has a
little bit of that if you look at it on
a side view you can see how it's got a
little bit of an overhang on the lip and
the nose helps to attach a shock wave
but it's not as efficient to go above
Mach 1.2 and that's okay actually it can
go that fast it can go faster but the
engine is working a little bit harder as
it gets into this 1.4 1.5 mock range
compared to something like an F4 or an
F-15 that's where they start to really
stretch their legs and run these designs
for optimizing maneuverability at these
speeds can be seen elsewhere too it's
air intake placement underneath the
aircraft a St difference to the Sid
mounted twin intakes of the F4 and the
thin elongated Wing that blends smoothly
into the fusel Lash with these Wing
extensions forward of the main Wing
these are called Leading Edge strikes
this air intake ensured the f-16's
engine was not starved of air during
high angle of attack Maneuvers with the
for body of the aircraft helping to
funnel and divert air directly into the
air intake however this does come with
some problems that needed to engineered
around on takeoff and Landing this air
intake is only 100 cm off the ground
this combined with the extremely thin
Wings made placement of the landing gear
difficult the forward landing gear could
not be mounted ahead of the air intake
as it would kick up debris into it and
they couldn't fit into the wings either
as the Thin aerodynamically optimized
Wing didn't have enough space the f-16's
landing gears are stored just behind the
air intake and in order to provide
enough stability and bracing on Landing
they need a unique folding mechanism to
swing them outward to create as large a
wheelbase as possible the front landing
gear which is steerable during taxi also
rotates 90° to lie flat just under the
engine Inlet above the inlet is a
boundary layer diverter Channel this
ensures the engine gets consistent
laminer flow as air travels along the
length of the aircraft it forms a layer
of slow-moving turbulent air called a
boundary layer if this air is allowed to
enter the engine it not only lowers
performance it can also damage the
engine as the turbine rotates it will
pass through the slow boundary air on
one side and then the fast freest stream
air on the other this means the force on
the turbine blades changes for each and
every rotation causing cyclical bending
a recipe for fatigue failure this
boundary layer diverter separates this
layer and diverts it underneath the
wings all of this ensures the engine can
operate as high as thrust as possible
even when the F-16 is performing extreme
Maneuvers which is exactly when it is
needed most as the plane bleeds energy
to produce lift it's essential that a
plane like this can continue to generate
effective lift during these Maneuvers
but typical Wings lose lift as angle of
attack increases Beyond a certain angle
as flow separates from the wing this is
called a stall these Leading Edge
strikes help to mitigate that they act
similarly to the canar of the s34 one of
the planes the F-16 will likely be going
up against in Ukraine with 19 of them
reportedly being taken down thus far in
the war canards and Leading Edge strikes
help produce lift during high angle of
attack Maneuvers canards placed close to
the wing like the Sab 37 vegan create a
Vortex that passes over the wing
ensuring the wing continues to get high
energy air flow during high angle of
attack Maneuvers which allows it to
continue generating lift during the
development of the F-16 General Dynamics
did consider a caner configuration
testing different configurations and
geometries including versions with no
strikes or canots with subscale models
in Wind tunnels testing through its
Optimum maneuvering speeds between 0.4
and 0.8 Mack the goal was to maximize
lift and minimize drag at high angles of
attack producing graphs like this and
these were used to compare designs as
they were narrowing down on the design
they consulted
and they found one area to improve on
the sharpness of the Leading Edge
General Dynamics had rounded the Leading
Edge of the wing to weaken these high
angle of attack vortices but NASA
advised them to sharpen the Leading Edge
in order to strengthen them the F-16
underwent a great deal of iterative
design in the Wind Tunnel phase before
eventually landing on the design we are
familiar with today with the long
Blended Leading Edge strike that makes
the F-16 immediately recognizable and
this comes with an added benefit it
provides enough space for the barrel of
the f-16's powerful 20 mm rotary Cannon
you can see the barrel of the m61 Vulcan
hiding here A minor clue to the weapon
hidden within the fuselage of the tiny
plane one of the early conclusions of
the Red Baron report was that the
lackluster ornament of the F4 made it
difficult for it to compete in Close
Quarter battles it lacked an internal
Cannon which left the F4 without
offensive options in close quarter
battles where missiles could not be
safely used the F4 was eventually
retrofitted with the m61 slung
underneath the plane but the F-16
looking to fix the problems of the past
came with the General Dynamics m61 vulin
rotary Gatling gun as standard and it
was packed neatly inside the plane
creating minimal aerodynamic drag the
m61 is the smaller cousin of the a10s
g8a and while it its rounds are tiny in
comparison the noise it admits still
packs a punch a massive Cannon for a
tiny
aircraft the six barrel Cannon fires
from the top position spinning 16 times
per second the Gatling gun spews 120 mm
rounds per second with an ammunition
drum capable of holding just 511 rounds
the full ammunition drum can be unloaded
in just over 5 Seconds the drum fits
neatly behind the pilot here and the
vibration of the gun firing on the
Pilot's left side is jaring for many new
pilots it is such a small fighter you
know when you and I I think I've said
this before when you get into an F-16
you sit down and you strap into that
it's not like you're sitting in the jet
it's like you're wearing the jet and the
the gun is right here as I as I sit
there in the cockpit the gun barrels the
muzzles are right back here it's it's
just Out Of Reach it's so close though
and so when you shoot the gun uh and
you're shooting 100 rounds a second of
mm it is unbelievably violent in the jet
but you're thinking about the Target
that you have to go and shoot and so uh
you know one of my experiences uh flying
the F-16 was I was teaching as an
instructor pilot at Luke Air Force Base
in Phoenix Arizona and so I had the
privilege of taking in Air Force pilots
they're wearing Wings they've graduated
Air Force pilot training but they're not
fighter pilots yet and putting them into
an F16 and then we would make sure that
everybody shot the gun in training in
fact they they had to qualify with the
gun as a weapon and so the first time
experience for anybody shooting the gun
in an F-16 is a little bit of an
emotional experience people would say
funny things they would cuss it was all
on the the the tapes the HUD tapes the
heads up display uh recordings and we
come back in the deef and we kind of
laugh at the students because they were
just they knew that they were going to
go shoot the gun and it was always uh
shooting at a Target on the ground is
when they would do this for the first
time uh strafe and uh so it's a little
bit intense you're diving at the ground
you're doing 450 500 knots pointed at
the ground obviously there's a survival
Instinct that kicks in there you're
trying to put the pipper on the target
you pull the trigger for the first time
and the whole jet shakes violently it's
like uh somebody started up a
chainsaw just in your left ear and the
whole jet is shaking and uh your hands
on the throttle there and I can always
remember every time I would shoot the
gun there's this there's this hard foam
insulation that's just behind the
closeout panel but the vibrations would
cause some of those little bits of foam
to Fleck off to flake off and they would
they would come around the close out
panel and every time I would go shoot
the gun uh for for practice for strafe
I'd come back and as I'm getting out of
the airplane I'd see like these little
yellow flexs of foam all over my green
flight suit on my left arm they would
just the vibrations was were so intense
um you get used to it after the first
the first time you shoot it it's a
little bit of an emotional event and
after that you're focused on I need to
put those rounds On Target so the
F-16 is incredibly well integrated as
far as a weapon system with that gun and
I will tell you that the both for air to
ground and also for air to air
the gun sits on the F-16 are incredibly
precise and even with Dynamics on the
aircraft even under Maneuvers in terms
of air to- a shoots where we're shooting
at a banner um there's not been a lot of
actual air to a dog fighting with the
gun in recent memory but the F16 is
incredibly accurate when it shoots at uh
air to- a practice targets to the point
of it's it's almost not even fair it
used to be kind of a scoring kind of a
skill thing and now you can just park
the the pipper on the Target open up and
it just shreds anything you pointed at
in terms of uh an air to- a Target and
then in terms of air to ground you can
be extremely precise with it it's it's
not quite a laser beam but you can be
extremely precise and there's even ways
that you can um couple up other sensors
on the aircraft and share information
even in a at night blacked out uh type
of close air support role you you can
hit what you want to hit on the ground
all from a gun hidden away inside the
tiny fighter if we follow this Leading
Edge strike down the wing we come to
another device designed to increase lift
at high angles of attack the Leading
Edge flap it deflects downwards during
high angle of attack Maneuvers to delay
stall allowing air to remain attached to
the wing surface when performing a
sustained turn at 0.9 mock at cruising
altitude it increases lift by 18% % and
decreases drag by
22% you can see them actuate here during
the 5G takeoff I performed with the
Thunderbirds back in 2019 the seam
between the Leading Edge flap and the
main Wing is barely noticeable and
fitting a control system into this Wing
which is only around 4 cm thick where
the actuator system needed to fit proved
a challenge the amount of torque needed
to actuate a control surface like this
at 0.9 Mach is not trivial to solve this
problem power power is transferred from
two hydraulic motors which convert the
pressure in the hydraulic system into
rotational motion the hydraulic drive
motor itself is tucked away behind the
m61 rotary Cannon next to the hydraulic
motor that drives the Cannon's rotation
and ammo drive system this power has to
be transferred to the wing and this is
done through a series of torque shafts
angular gearboxes and down another
series of torque shafts with rotary
actuators in between this Leading Edge
flap is not controlled by the pilot
however it's controlled automatically by
the flight computer and the F-16 was
groundbreaking in this regard the F-16
was the first fighter aircraft to have a
flyby wire system controlling every
control surface the Leading Edge flaps
the flapper Rons the rudder and the
horizontal tail of the F-16 are not
controlled directly by the pilot a flyby
wire system uses a network of sensors
wires and computers as well as the
Pilot's own input to control the plane
the f 16 was employing this new
technological Wizardry to allow it to
efficiently spend the energy its single
jet engine provided traditional flight
Control Systems up to this point used a
mechanical system connected directly to
the Pilot's controls to manipulate the
flight surfaces this is footage of the F
Force control system a heavy and
complicated network of cables rods
linkages and hydraulics it even has a 2
kg Bob weight attached to the pilot
stick a mechanism designed to to make it
harder to pull the stick as G's increase
an analog feedback system to provide the
pilot with analog feedback on speed the
F4 also featured a diaphragm that
deflected with ram air taken from this
Probe on the vertical fin this
introduced a force that acted to push
the stick backwards and indicated to the
pilot to adjust a trim setting this
system not only added a huge amount of
weight to the F4 reducing its
maneuverability it also added workload
to the pilot and was more vulnerable to
damage in dog fights with little
redundancy with a flyby wire system none
of this was needed the first batch of
f-16s actually had a stick that was
immovable it was just for sensing later
a small amount of movement was added
after Pilots complained so the the
non-movable stick kind of little known
fact you know the original F16 it wasn't
a locked Martin product it was General
Dynamics and they had made the f111
previously and the weapons system
operator on the F1 11 had a a small
joystick that they could use to steer
the attack radar and that was a force
based movement it wasn't really a a
joystick that would move it was just the
apply force and so they took that same
concept and then they put it into the
F-16 stick so it was sort of a General
Dynamics thing of we've got a force
transducer a control inceptor is what
you'd call that so what it turns out
though is that the
human body does really well with knowing
where your limbs hands are moving
knowing the position of your body is
something that you naturally do pretty
well and that is something called
proprioceptive feedback well when I have
a force-based inceptor I don't get that
proprioceptive feedback anymore and it's
really hard to
judge it's something that I think if you
challenge yourself to go pick up a a a
small weight at the gym and ask yourself
how much does that weigh without looking
at it it's actually kind of hard to
guess when you're down in those few
pounds range and the maximum Force you
can put on the F16 Sid stick is 25 lbs
so it's kind of hard to tell the
difference between 15 lb and 15.2 lb we
don't do very well with that we do a lot
better with knowing how far we've pulled
something and so the original F-16
controls didn't move and what pilots
found was that they were having a
difficult time the test pilots at
Edwards were having a difficult time
judging exactly how hard they would move
the controls and so they would think
they were going to get a certain
response from the Jet and then they
weren't and then they pull harder too
hard and then they'd get a different
response there is a a phenomenon called
pilot induced oscillations or Pilot in
the loop
oscillations sometimes it's just
shortened to Pio and the
F16 even to this day particularly if you
have a lot of wings stores can have a
little bit of a wing rock on landing and
if you look at some videos of f-16's
Landing sometimes you can find if they
have Wing tanks or they're bringing back
some bombs that they didn't expend
you'll find an F-16 that'll sort of do
this little back and forth uh Wing Rock
and that is still to this day it's an
artifact of having a side stick that
doesn't move very much because it's one
of those things that in terms of the
mind to the hand ey hand coordination
you start to make a movement by the time
you see the effect it's more than you
wanted so you take it out you put in a
correction by the time the correction
takes effect it's more than you wanted
you see it you come back it's a feedback
loop in our minds and now Pio is kind of
a dirty word in aircraft design and
nobody wants any pios I'll tell you
pios pilot induced oscillations are like
snakes and some snakes are very
dangerous and some snakes are not and so
the Pio that's remaining in the F-16 in
terms of its wing rock on Final uh at
Landing is not super dangerous these
pilot induced oscillations can also be
naturally stabilized through Pass of
stability where the plane naturally
self-corrects itself without pilot input
however the F16 was the first aircraft
in history to do away with passive
stability and make the plane
intentionally unstable in flight this
was done because it lowers the energy
needed to fly and maneuver we can
understand why with this simple analogy
here we have two situations a ball
placed on top of a hill and a ball
placed in a valley if we push the ball
on top of the hill even a tiny bit it
will begin to accelerate down the hill
and will not stop until we put energy in
to slow it down this is an unstable
system the opposite is true for the ball
in the valley apply a force and the ball
Will Roll uphill and gravity will now
provide a restoring Force to bring it
back it may oscillate back and forth a
few times before coming to a stop but it
will eventually return to its original
position this is a stable system we want
to tailor our stability to find a
balance between these two scenarios
where we can cause a rapid change in
Direction with a small energy input
while also managing the amount of energy
required to get back to our original
position this is called relax static
stability the F6 16's pitch stability is
one of the areas where this idea was
applied one of the key factors that
affects pitch stability is the location
of the center of gravity and center of
lift the center of gravity for the F4 is
located about here this is the point at
which all lift will act around it's like
the fulcrum on a seesaw as a result of
the wing design the center of lift is
slightly behind the center of gravity
this would force the plane to pitch
downwards but the horizontal stabilizer
provides a counteracting downwards Force
this isn't ideal we are wasting energy
on downwards lift we need upwards lift
to fly it also increases the amount of
energy the F4 needs to input to change
its pitch when it pitches upwards the
force on the horizontal stabilizer
decreases because of reduced air flow
and as a result the weight of the plane
acting through the center of gravity
forward of the center of lift wants to
move the nose down again but the pilot
is trying to pitch the plane on up and
this natural stability is fighting them
so more kinetic energy has to be wasted
by converting it to lift and drag with
an increased elevator deflection the
F-16 is different its Center of lift is
ahead of its center of gravity in par
thanks to those Leading Edge strikes
pushing the center of lift forward this
means to balance the plane the
horizontal stabilizer needs to create
upwards lift this is useful lift and
reduces The energy needed to keep the
plane airborne and increases our maximum
lift pushing this line on our energy
maneuverability diagram up increasing
our turn rate however it's an unstable
system when the plane pitches up it
increases the angle of attack on the
wing and increases the lift because the
center of lift is ahead of the center of
gravity this forces the nose up even
more in an air-to-air battle energy
isn't just a fuel burning problem energy
is needed to maneuver and as we spend it
our ability to maneuver diminishes until
we replenish it by gaining speed or
altitude again any fighter pilot will
tell you speed is life and as a fighter
pilot energy management is one of the
most important things that you can do
it's part of your situational awareness
in that combat Arena you don't want to
get slow and you don't want to put
yourself in a place where you are
vulnerable and now I can't turn I can't
move I can't get my sensors or my
weapons engaged where I need to and
that's not just an air-to-air thing
that's in every aspect of being a
fighter pilot and that's even engaging
in an air to ground Arena because often
times when you're engaging air to ground
an interdiction Mission a strike Mission
or close air support Mission well you're
supporting friendly troops on the ground
but there's also people that really
don't like you in the vicinity and they
have weapons also and so you have to
maintain that energy to be able to evade
uh to be able to move out of the way if
you're getting shot at and so so with
the energy management uh on the F-16
it's interesting that this this Jet
doesn't really talk to you in terms of
feedback to the pilot it doesn't really
shake and Rattle and vibrate uh like a
lot of other aircraft will do I've flown
the F16 I've also flown the F-15 the F18
the A10 and those aircraft will talk to
you those other aircraft will talk to
you a lot more than the F16 the F-16
just feels smooth all the time whether
you're 200 knots and really slow or
you're 600 Nots and really fast it just
sort of does what you ask it to do you
think you move the controls just a tiny
bit and the aircraft responds um so
managing your energy becomes a
situational awareness challenge for the
fighter pilot and a lot of that's helped
now with the joint helmet mounted
queuing system or jemic is what it's
called where right there in your right
eye you've got your air speed you've got
your altitude you've got your G and so
you can engage visually in that fight I
can keep my eyes on the
the target keep situational awareness
and I don't have to look back in at my
heads up display or down at the console
to see how fast I'm going and how high
I'm going you get the feel for it you
get a feel for how the aircraft is
responding but that's where experience
comes in and it's imperative experience
and training comes in it's imperative to
maintain that energy awareness in any
kind of fight the unstable design of the
F-16 helped fighter pilots like David to
manage energy more efficiently but to
maintain Rin control of an unstable
fighter a pilot would have to make
constant tiny Corrections a task deemed
impossible before flyby wire systems
were invented the system consists of a
network of accelerometers Gyros and air
speeed sensors all feeding into a
central computer that manages the work
this instability makes the plane
extremely Nimble ready to change
Direction with very little energy input
we could see this in practice on the
First Flight of the F-16 prototype the
yf-16 a flight that was never supposed
to happen this was intended to be a
short test along the runway but the
early control logic of the plane would
not allow the engine nozzle to open to
cut thrust if the wheels had left the
ground meaning even at idle the plane
was generating too much thrust then the
plane rolled left which caused the pilot
to counteract it with a roll right
command but again the control logic of
the early prototype was not dialed in
with control input resulting in higher
roll than expected at such a low speed
resulting in an over correction leading
to an oscillation with this being the
first full flyby wire plane there were
many lessons to be learned along the way
but the benefits it now provides are
gamechanging it helps the pilot get the
most out of the plane so for example
with an F-16 the airframe is limited to
9gs and so I can go and pull back on the
controls on an F-16 and if I am less
than about 300 knots or so actually more
like 400 knots I'm not going to get 9gs
it's just that's how much lift the
aircraft can make but once I get above
about 400 to 450 knots now the wing on
the F-16 is capable of creating at least
9gs in fact it's capable of creating a
lot more than 9gs but what that flyby
wire system does is when I start pulling
back all the way to the stop it goes to
9gs and it sits there even if the wing
even if the aerodynamic
uh effect of the whole airframe is that
it could generate 15 G's or 20 G's the
fly by wire system says hey I know
you're asking for your best possible
turn I'm just going to give you N9 G's
because we're not going to break the
airplane or again in like a slow speed
fight where I'm having to it's less than
300 knots I'm having to crank the nose
around to either bring my nose onto the
adversary or maybe I'm trying to
out of the way of an adversary's weapon
system
pull suddenly on the controls of an
aircraft and your angle of attack is
going to increase rapidly all right well
with a lot of more conventional aircraft
you're worried about things like stall
well the F-16 doesn't really stall in
the same kinds of ways but that fly by
wire system says hey I know that if you
get past about 26° angle of attack bad
things are going to start to happen in
terms of the controlability the F-16
stops
behaving as predictably above 26° angle
of attack and so the fly by wire system
simply says that's where I'm going to
stop you right there and I'm going to
give you up to 26° or 9gs and do with
that whatever you need to a plane
capable of 9g Maneuvers is not much use
if the pilot cannot remain conscious
during them the F-16 has some
interesting adaptions in the cockpit for
this traditionally the control stick was
mounted centrally between the Pilot's
legs
this made it mechanically simpler with
the network of mechanical linkages being
Central and symmetric throughout the
plane it also allowed the pilots to use
both hands to wrestle the control
surfaces into position during HG
Maneuvers as the air flowing by them
tried to push them back down for the
F-16 this wasn't a problem and the
control stick was mounted conveniently
on the Pilot's right hand console a
comfortable resting position that makes
it far easier for the pilot to control
the plane while trying to stay conscious
at 9gs the seat is also reclined by 30°
this makes the F16 feel like an
executive office in the sky with
unobstructed 360° views thanks to the
bubble canopy but it also comes with
major advantages in increasing the
Pilot's G tolerance the most common
GeForce of pilot experiences is directly
down when flying in a straight line even
cells in your body have inertia in that
direction and when suddenly pitching the
plane upwards those cells want to
continue traveling in that direction
this isn't too much of a problem for
cells that stay fixed but your blood
cells are free to travel through your
body and in a scenario like this they
race in the direction of that travel
pooling in your lower extremities this
can starve the Pilot's brain of oxygen
and they can pass out as a result this
effect can be minimized by placing the
pilot flat on their back with the entire
body aligned blood wouldn't have to
fight gravity to get to the brain but
this position isn't practical the F-16
found a compromise with a 30° recline
reducing the pressure on the Heart by an
equivalent of about 1G the recline also
makes it easier to fit taller Pilots
into the small forward fuselage of the
F-16 another measure to increase the
Pilot's G tolerance is the git a pilot's
git contains multiple air bladders that
are connected directly to the F-16 when
the plane is instructed to perform a HG
maneuver it immediately begins to pump
compressed air into these bladders this
squeezes the Pilot's legs to limit the
volume available for blood to pool into
the F-16 is a 45-year-old aircraft and
many advances have occurred in aviation
since its made in Flight stealth
technology and interconnected
intelligence networks have been the main
focus for fifth generation aircraft like
the F35 that have been slowly replacing
the F-16 but one thing has not changed
since 1975
physics the F-16 pushes the boundaries
of maneuverability for a fighter
aircraft and the pilot inside it's a
highly capable fighter aircraft that the
strongest Air Force in the world deemed
capable of continuing service until
2048 the plane will be a major asset in
the next phase of the fight for
Ukraine's Freedom providing Essential
Air Support to the Troops on the ground
as they attempt to push forward through
entrenched Russian defenses Ukraine has
been targeting longrange anti-aircraft
batteries with success and captured oil
platforms off the coast of Crimea that
were housing Russian sensors all to
clear the way for Ukrainian Su 24s to
get close enough to launch cruise
missiles targeting high value Russian
Assets in Crimea including a kilo class
submarine the F-16 can also carry these
cruise missiles every asset in the
Ukrainian Air Force is going to play a
vital role in Ukraine Fight For Freedom
having an actual fighter pilot add
context to the story was incredibly
valuable helping us truly understand the
power of those energy maneuverability
diagrams we ended up talking to David
for nearly 2 hours and ended up cutting
an incredibly interesting story from
this video about how he helped develop
an automatic obstacle avoidance system
for the F-16 that has saved many lives a
fascinating system that works in a way I
didn't expect I had a assumed it's
simply used radar to measure distance
but that is not how it works you can
watch that extra video on nebula right
now along with an uncut explanation of
energy maneuverability diagrams access
usually cost $5 a month but you can get
access right now with the huge
discounted price of 250 a month using
the link in the description bonus videos
are just one benefit to nebula you will
also get adree versions of our videos at
a fraction of the price of YouTube
premium with with YouTube cracking down
on ad blockers this is the best way to
support our Channel while not having to
deal with ads interrupting your viewing
experience something I find really
valuable while watching long form videos
when I am taking flights to shoot
interviews I often download videos from
nebula which you can do by the way and
watch them on the flight you will also
get access to our original World War II
series the logistics of D-Day and the
Battle of Britain as well as real life
Loris modern conflict series that deep
dives into conflicts like the war in
Ukraine along with originals from some
of your favorite creators like mustard
practical engineering Neo and went over
Productions nebula is simply the best
place to watch our videos no ads bonus
videos and exclusive High budget
Originals all for the price of 250 a
month